[Music]
before you board the bumper car they
need to know how fat you are
yes if you live at the chocolate
fountain there shall be no space
mountain
an amusement park in australia which
seems redundant cat
is accused of fat shaming people for
imposing a new guest weighing policy and
if the guests are huge employees have
been asked to stop yelling crikey you're
fat
adventure world has reportedly started
posting weight limits for their rides
which they've been enforcing with
self-serve way stations that flash green
or red if the rioter meets the
requirements if it's red you're too fat
to ride and you're immediately removed
and taunted by kangaroos
but you know what finally you big folks
know how short people feel about those
embarrassing ride requirements
i am tired of people measuring me before
i get on the subway
the park ceo says the new weigh-in
stations were added to comfort patrons
and serve as a quote writer weight
safety assessment scale for the operator
but the policy has boomerang
with lots of aussies upset with the
whole thing we went to one for comment
i find it shameful you would kick people
out for being too big bound anyone they
don't let on splash mountain looks like
margot robbie to me mate speaking of
hotties shout out to joe mackey on the
show tonight i heard you've been keeping
catering busy this week mate
[Applause]
yeah he's got a thing for pockets
but hey
this show
is against fat shaming we're more about
health so we sent kat temp out to
explore a new exercise option in
nashville
i've been searching everywhere for a
fitness plan that fits into my busy
career woman who drinks lifestyle in
nashville i finally found the
inspiration to create my own okay i need
to bring in clay travis though you've
started some businesses you're a
nashville guy will you help me get
cataton
off the ground i think it's a gold mine
i think i think this if warren buffett
were here with us right now he would
want to invest immediately every single
bachelor
bachelorette in nashville wants to get
insanely drunk but also not get super
fat this is the perfect combination
that's the women can have it all yes
there you go
i've done this once before and i just
want to let you know you're going to be
sweating by the time we finish
vodka pretty much right out of the pores
but will i care
is the question you have enough alcohol
everything feels better it's been my
experience that's going to be the name
of my memoir you know you're in your 30s
and half your friends are gym friends
half your friends are bar friends this
is the way to bring them together
it's honestly a perfect idea
[Music]
new business idea like peloton but with
alcohol what do you think
fabulous fabulous oh yeah it'll work i
was just going to say we should go get a
drink we want you all the time we do
watch me doing what
do you think that this would be a good
option for a pregnant woman
uh i do not
why not
lots of um
i don't know the alcohol probably and
the pedaling how far along are we trying
to get the baby out i say go for it
uh
no i only meant the biking part of
course
what is your official
doctor's opinion of my fitness idea as a
doctor
i'm not a doctor what are you doing i
just paid you five bucks to say you're a
doctor
i'm a nurse nobody asked you that's fine
that works
[Music]
i the people have spoken uh this is
great you know thanks to uh clay travis
and my of course brilliant business
brain i'm about to be really rich i'm
kind of excited for you to be really
rich what do you think the first thing
you're gonna buy is
um a house
i don't think you could do that cat in
uh in new york city right you'd be too
busy running over people passed out on
the street yeah
yeah you couldn't do that in new york
city um at all i was confused by the
whole story with the australia amusement
park weighing machines because i thought
australia was wasn't it like completely
locked down right like you get arrested
if you go to the bar but their amusement
park weighing machines are open yep
that doesn't make sense as a country
yeah joe how do you feel about the
weighing stations is it amusing to you
uh greg i'm a celebrity so i don't have
time for weigh stations or
or eye contact or tipping
and as someone who's had more seconds
this week than a motion to recall gavin
newsom this is offensive
uh i think it's even scarier for the
people who ride the roller coaster that
get on because apparently uh
too much weight is dangerous
yes
build better roller coasters australia
yeah well yeah what tyrus uh have you
ever heard this is a great idea this is
amazing we used to see we used to tell
the truth
use your big ass nose when you're in
line if it says 225 you know if you're
not 225 yes
and usually it'd be someone in your
family going yo t you know you can't
ride this right
and be like shut up mom
[Laughter]
we used to be able to handle that you
knew it yeah i was at 14 i was six six i
wasn't getting on roller coasters
anymore i knew it was over then when i
was like 300 pounds i was like you know
what point of pride i'm too big for this
puny human stuff
okay
because we were able to take truths now
everyone lies oh yes the scale says 360
but i identify as 125.
[Music]
so now
are you lying
we'll call them chunky buffers all you
lion chunky buffers you step on the
scale green you're in red you're fat
sorry
yeah that's a way to tell people that
maybe they should lose weight maybe this
is a positive thing bring them to the
immune bring it yeah instead of telling
them they're overweight bring them to
the amusement park it's a long journey
to australia but it might be worth it
well first of all i was an nfl
cheerleader so you want to talk about
fat shaming like australia hold my beer
that's number one and number two to your
point i think this is this is present
day in a nutshell that everyone loses
their mind over the wrong point i would
rather be embarrassed than dead because
that ride was where you hang in the sky
so yeah if you're too fat to hang from
the sky from a machine then please keep
your feet on yeah and if you're that fat
you could kill someone else
yes
i just saw a commercial that said we now
have body equality no you now have an
excuse for people not to go work out
that's all it is it's a body equality
you're chubby
you don't have 8x sorry ma'am
all right or sir what i've been damned
there a biscuit from 500 pounds i think
i can speak on this
that is true hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else